okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to jolly 3 now
jolly 3 is a game that I played during
the five five nights at Freddy's fan
games video which I did last week if you
haven't seen the beginning of this game
go watch that video it's about the
fourth game I played in because I'm
gonna be picking this up from where I
last left off unless it dumps me at the
beginning of the game again but I hope
it doesn't because I only got one crack
at this and I didn't do too well so
we're gonna play this to completion the
entire game in once it out quickly
righty-ho yeah I know the whole drill
okay okay alright there's no much time
we have to hurry wait what I can't hack
say I need to save work number do you
know anybody get that room you yep me I
know program okay thank you
it's easy yeah easy I've tried this
before it didn't go so well going
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
like that yeah hey hey hey whoa I don't
like that at all oh stop it go away I'm
busy doing hacking skills stop it's not
that shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up I don't have time for you hey
whoa whoa whoa hey oh well that's not
good I guess that's just the way things
are now how many of these do I gotta do
[Music]
oh I don't like that oh I don't like
that
I don't know what and what's my wife I
don't know what you're talking about but
I don't like it I know you see me that's
precisely the problem why do I have to
do so many of these stay with staying
the words would you say - uh-oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa easy there right whoa
okay that's hard all right
wow that is a sack of [ __ ] huh
but this game is so cool this game is so
incredibly well-made I'm just I'm just
impressed I'm just beyond impressed by
[Music]
me I know I'm gonna try not to [ __ ] this
one up stop stop just stop stop no stop
stop stop I don't want to soar on your
wings that's hard that's hard that's
really hard that's really obscenely
absurdly hard okay alright okay that's a
little bit difficult
goddamn sack of [ __ ] oh and keep the
phone down putting the phone on will
activate sweetie oh okay I started it no
I won't be shy you're gonna go away yes
okay okay I think I'm gonna get this I
think I'm gonna get it totally fine I
think oh oh I know I know one more I
know one more dude you don't need to
tell me one more I'm counting them
ah this is good or bad I'm gonna assume
it's good I'm gonna assume it's real
good
oh I'm gonna sue MIT's though okay okay
I got a block good reading is power
knowledge is your weapon against Satan I
don't know I did it
this job sucks I'm just gonna come out
and say this job is a bag of dick why do
I need a war Wow how is this a place yep
this place is amazing it well not really
amazing but you know what I mean right
oh ah
follow me I don't know if I wanna oh oh
no oh no hello
it's a Bonnie animatronic it smells like
wet socks and blood it's a Freddy
animatronic smells like dildos glitter
all over it it's a GK animatronic it
smells like birthday cake oh that's so
nice why are we in the bathrooms that's
not okay where's the bathroom connected
to the kitchen so here's the kitchen
where we cook our pizza it may not be
the best but it's pizza I also figured
out you're a man of few words eh yeah I
don't talk very much well let's continue
okay all right wait just let me just
hump this oven for a little bit here
yeah
okay good I'm set I'm ready to go oh let
me hump you for a little bit yeah yeah
all right I'm all good here's the
bathrooms and where employees can dress
up as one of fazbear animals let's keep
going all right purple guy whatever you
say let me just hang on this ain't right
now something ain't right about this
stuff this porridge is too hot this
porridge is too cold somebody touch you
must be Gallo what's up
here's the arcade we've got very few
games but the customers love them
anyways I have the high score on all the
games then again I have lots of free
time maybe too much free time maybe just
enough free time to stuff some kids into
animatronic suits well your first day on
the job requires you to organize the
costumes in order here's your list
before I go to work what's that room
over there that room there are
animatronics in there they were unused
one of their names is jolly and I don't
know who the other one is okay thanks
for telling me
okay I'm gonna go see oh okay where am I
going
this feels wrong ah this is weird
where is this oh hello hello okay I'm
just gonna hump this wall mmm
nope nothing there ah foxy are you here
foxy no this is let me just stick my
head up this skirt here alright oh here
we go
oh that looks ominous why are you in
here Eric
you know you shouldn't be a boss I am oh
no you're staying put here let me tell
you something Eric you may think you're
smart or sneaky but in this place no one
is going to find out about this room do
you understand me yeah yes sir okay and
you do go back to your costume room grab
that list and get your job done you can
leave afterwards okay alrighty then
Thank You boss glad no one's gonna yeah
okay something tells me that today is
gonna be even worse than yesterday I
just have this raw I just have this
obscenely funkalicious feeling but maybe
just maybe it's gonna be equally as
there oh yeah okay no beat it yeah what
fun iam way worse hey here's some advice
why don't you try and repair yeah that
was my inclination oh hey what
okay why did that happen
I am okay that's not good okay we're
good okay the cameras have got to be
pretty better the flu all hi okay well
you are there and you exist okay that's
weird
okay well alright you're nearby I'm
ready for a gas attack are you my gas is
good I think and your ass is gas
oh I've got my fist ready all right well
that's not good okay there's got to be
one of these things that's probably
gonna be oh they're all there one of the
fans has to be breaking soon oh boy yah
yah yah yah try to repair this I guess
[Music]
okay so fine
one of the fans has got to be going soon
Oh two of them there yeah that's hello
hello okay we're fine
oh that's not good oh where is it where
is it where who where what why where who
what and why
oh [ __ ] shitty dicks oh there you are
boy it's gas clock oh okay we just need
to fill the gas back up I'm gonna repair
it first and then I'm gonna fill it oh
that's probably not goddamn awful okay
it's fine though everything's fine
yeesh my god this is [ __ ] insanity
there's gotta be there's gotta be
[ __ ] all over my [ __ ] okay if I can
just keep my head out of my ass and I
should be able to get through this okay
these guys okay but it's fine I'm
already halfway through the night which
is far right not looking at you oh I
know I know you're about this is no
point do you even look at these without
risking death is there okay
we're fine we are 100% fine oh boy why
do I do that why do I even bother
looking
Oh for might go down right now I think
12 and 32 all right all right that's not
good oh no oh no oh no oh twelve
thirteen eleven surprised it was 11
who'da thought
yeah okay got a refill and repair okay
we're fine we're fine we're almost
service we're almost through this
goddamn night well no why why did I do
that why did I want to look into bodies
eyes
oh so tenderly they're so enticing what
have you got for me straight ahead is it
gonna be straight ahead yeah you know it
is why are these testing chambers by the
way what kind of horrible animatronic
place needs testing chambers I guess
this is where they're all made Islam
come on I don't want to I don't want to
do that
oh I got the code right here passcode is
nine two six seven three what okay Hey
that was easy
well that was easy huh what do you do
staples button I don't know baby love
burns eternal I don't know you're
getting kind of philosophical here I'm
not in the mood for that are you talking
about lover forever cuz my love for you
is forever
[Music]
I'm okay with that okay I don't
understand any of the words that you're
saying but I'm assuming that I can time
travel now is that what I'm to assume
okay all right bye I'm gonna pass out
now guess I'm done I guess I'm done life
is [ __ ] love is never gonna happen for
me oh I can't wait to go to Freddy today
that's so wonderful
yes when we get there here's how things
are gonna go I plan every detail of my
life daddy has to get his work done and
while I'm doing that I call myself daddy
and you should do I'll buy you some
tokens so you can play in the arcade
after I'm done we can order pizza and
watch the show does that sound like a
good plan or what does daddy make good
plans or what yeah well well should we
get going yes
get in the car daddy needs to go to work
all right
okay all right daddy needs to go to a
super special secret workplace here we
are
are you coming silly yeah one second
okay that's not something a responsible
parent would do don't get in why dad
please stay in the car Zoey I beg you
okay again that's not something a
responsible parent would do
I'm just saying that a responsible
parent probably wouldn't do that okay I
found a bunch of papers what are you
talking about good idea to play for
money work
we what the hell what the hell what the
hell
jeezum try to play game here and try to
listen to the goddamn tapes I don't know
why I keep looking at that I don't know
why the demon soul of chicas here to
kill me everything is horrible and I
hate it
why is it why am I looking there I don't
know uh and apparently of you
my gas time okay apparently there's some
kind of code that's hidden around
everywhere and I don't know what that's
about good okay geez everything this is
just goddamn nightmare all the time all
right okay all right well and it got it
out I don't know I got the fear burps so
one of these fans all right okay aren't
you cute the way you Boop and your beef
all over the place don't do that to me
what's going on here bye definitely
definitely 100% didn't oh boy oh boy oh
boy
I didn't do that why he did I have no
idea what happened oh we're back we're
in trouble
oh we're in trouble no we're fine yeah
we're not fine we might be fine but
we're not fine if you could just [ __ ]
off for one goddamn second and I could
get my hand out of my ass and I could
figure out a way out of this stupid [ __ ]
we're okay
oh seven my break oh five also a culprit
a one oh [ __ ] so you got to put it down
is that what you gotta do oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there it is yeah [ __ ] nah [ __ ]
no uh okay we're fine
oh god I need to stop being on that
goddamn menu so that I can stop thinking
that everything is gonna [ __ ] break
Oh last hour we got this I just need to
not let anything get in our way oh my
god this is just a panic that is a
straight-up panic from start to finish
okay but we're fine I don't like the way
you got a slack job oh no oh no no no
you're all happening at once and I don't
like it done yes all right I did it I am
the man I am the man with the plan this
is gonna be the last area to go into so
it's gonna be like the last area that I
can go tours there gonna be some other
secret some other secret [ __ ] here
I just scratch my forehead okay
what what what
[Music]
you want to run that by me again
oh this is bad oh you know thanks
harmonious visitors oh baby it's alright
you don't you doing precious baby you
don't owe you don't just didn't you just
say she passed didn't you just say that
don't touch me you don't care other
people to me she don't care hee-hee
oh you terrible
he's a gem that you do for money
hey engaging spicy
how many can eat cheap juices in new 80
we have noticed it people coming don't
out there and it stays that way okay I
have to give you credit it's fascinating
I managed to three nights will be no
last oh lift body up put body down lift
up lift up I'm listing all I'm lifting
whoa oh I'm lifting so mistily I've
never lifted my ass this hard in my life
oh god oh god oh god I don't know if I'm
doing anything I'm trying real hard okay
alright
okay okay okay all right
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead all yep I'm
dead did he want Oh what did you want me
to do I was lifting up my body and I was
slamming it down I was doing about as
good as I could have slammed all right
let's try this again if I have to go
through that goddamn speech again I'm
gonna be pissed off
try mashing oh really just try Matt okay
I am mashing I'm really mashing it guys
I'm really mashing it whew Oh God my
hands oh they're cramping up oh boy here
comes death here comes the death cramp
go oh boy here comes the death cramp
[Music]
Oh God ha I'm about to I'm about to
start sweating that was just so much
intense mashing good God 30 old man
heads on oh my god well I did that my
job's done I quit
also I quit did I mention that I quit
did I mention how I quit because I feel
like that's an important detail that's
being overlooked here I quit and quit oh
oh
kid you you're not supposed to leave Zoe
Zoe whatever it told you Joey
well here I go oh this is not good this
is this is not good Wow Zoe this is um
oh that's not good
they have no heads they have no heads
okay well let's go to the place where I
think I'm supposed to go well it's not
here it's not the bathroom okay
hmm William you need to stop this you're
going to get in trouble for this
hahahahaha you think I'll ever stop I'm
already dead inside so why not share
that with the outside world please don't
hurt me
Freddie I want to sing and dance with
you woah why why did you do this I told
you why there is no meaning in this life
I'm already dead and now that kid is
dead
but why did you do this I mean you're
ruining your life piece by piece
sacrifice them please please don't hurt
me I want to eat pizza with chica
oh you can't hide in there forever
William you do okay yes I do I'm so
sorry dad William don't you do this this
is my daughter don't who says I can't
please don't
dad I'm sorry at least won't have to
feel any pain that's [ __ ] up okay I
guess I'm still working for some reason
I'm still working here
gay yeah I got a job and a paycheck yeah
I'm so happy yeah and I'm sorry for that
I thought you [ __ ] out you know
just be more careful next time
[Music]
okay thanks boss yeah boss from the past
phone guy I guess talking about the
original five nights of Freddie's place
whatever it doesn't matter that is a
scary place okay so everything is gonna
be horrible this night I don't even know
okay everything's fine everything's fine
I don't know if this is gonna be like
the last night or something but I have a
funny feeling that it might be because
there's only one other hall to do it and
also why am I still going in here why
would that [ __ ] not tell me that
there was an active animatronic in the
hall that was gonna kidnap me and send
me down the crusher yeah I don't like it
I don't like any of it but I gotta do it
I guess for some [ __ ] reason oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] welp [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] God [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
where's it there it is go ah [ __ ] babe i
am i dead i'm dead okay alright [ __ ]
come on are you kidding with that
[ __ ] oh my god how could I even win
that money sex is war nope you're not
gonna give me like that because I know
your tricks and I'm too smart for you
and even if I wasn't very smart I'd
still be too smart for you because
you're a big dumb
tronic remember what i don't know what
that was at all okay that's the thing
that can happen apparently we're just
gonna pretend like everything is
hunky-dory and I'm not worried bye oh
boy
what is that oh boy yep that's what I
thought it was okay can I please click
on these oh come on no you can't do that
that's not fair
oh that's not fair
god [ __ ] you uh [ __ ] off you can't do
that that's not fair it's so unfair
you're such a sack of [ __ ] okay doing
all right so far we managed to survive
something and so long as we duck
immediately whenever we see chica like
that you sack of [ __ ] then everything's
gonna be fine
even if we're about to repair fam it's
more important ha ha ha I thought that
was an animatronic I mean technically I
guess it was the ghost of an animatronic
but I'm not here to split hairs I'm just
here to survive what is why why did that
why what the [ __ ] where did why what
what a load of [ __ ]
I just died for no reason ah ok well
this sucks [ __ ] dick God [ __ ] [ __ ]
you just [ __ ] repair it
oh come on [ __ ] fat donkey dicks
[ __ ] [ __ ] Aronian jeez come on come
on come on come on come on come on
what's happening why I don't know what's
happening oh it's that [ __ ] alarm and
the goddamn yeah I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine
huh last hour last hour goddamn it
goddamn it goddamn it cuz we got a mica
demon
goddamn and goddamn goddamn a goddamn
uh-oh god damn up alright
ten seconds oh we got this he's a good
easy boy
easy peasy easy peasy and just like that
we did it last room I think maybe maybe
not but there might be the last room all
right only one way to find out is there
an active animatronic in the hall
probably probably definitely okay here
we go
we're going into it and we're doing okay
we're not dead yet
we're just saying something because
that's touching any electrical device is
dangerous and triggers the facility
security system right yeah sure okay
all right try finding another lender
thief why do I always have to do this
and why are there so many safes around
here
well he's everything locked up in a safe
I mean I understand security and
everything but one is everything have to
be individual firewall I don't want it
all right I'm gonna need your disable to
fire wall so I can hack my way into the
safe I don't want to do that you need a
virus I can't see me the buyer software
it's a virus that doesn't make any sense
to me what what one for this program is
executed it will disable the facility's
firewall yeah got it
keep going Oh God oh that doesn't sound
good
oh wait I see that holy [ __ ]
okay wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
uh uh uh uh I'm dead I'm dead I'm not a
little bear what do they do
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] ah I'm super
[ __ ] I'm super fun a goddamn typing
puzzle well if you're bad at typing
you're gonna be bad at this I guess
there was no way to like flash to get
them away so I guess it's just a purely
skill based thing Wow what was that book
weight book whoa what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] wait may appear and the cameras do
not switch cameras and wait until it uh
uh aah metal foxy oh boy alright well
alright then that would have been
helpful a little bit ago oh don't use
your phone to make maxi go back ok that
makes sense that's easy enough
yep it's a birthday girl my girl easy
easy ZZ I got this shut up shut up shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm right here shut up go
back go back go back to where you came
from you sack of poopy you big ol sack
oh you're about to find out what my
fists main purposes and it's not happy
no no no no no no no go back go back go
back go back go back go back go back go
back go back go back
thank you go back please go back go back
to where you came from please please
I'm right here yet douche one more ok
easy enough easy enough
easy up initiate dot adder SSL
okay I did it I thank God dad and I'll
think I doubt it all right you should be
okay for eight to one mm-hmm cassettes
wait are these the cassettes you were
talking about that I got already boy no
is there more I don't even know if it's
gonna be able to possible do another
night of that oh boy this stone look
good
oh hello okay all right oh excuse me I'm
very sneaky very extremely sneaky okay
here we go I guess
that's no good okay so I somehow got a
sneak by all this [ __ ] oh come on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it all right I'll wait then
I'll wait in vibrate
nailed it nailing it nailed it nailed it
perfect oh oh well this ain't good
[Music]
hmm walk okay I'll get in okay I'm in
I'm in a truck why did I want to get in
the truck what was the point of that
what was the point of getting in a truck
and there can't possibly be another
night here I don't I don't agree I just
don't agree I don't agree no no no you
asked no no
[Music]
that sucks
okay well that sucks oh boy oh boy oh
this is how this nights gonna go oh I'm
super happy about this I'm all smiles
all day baby
all smiles all day yeah come on well I'm
at lost I can't find it it's it doesn't
exist there's no there's there's not
there was none I went to every [ __ ]
camera this is gonna be a [ __ ]
sometimes I wonder why why why why would
anybody do this ha ha no okay you I'm
right there right there I'm right there
I'm so right there
yes yes I am I am Sam I am Sam I am just
give me over there repair it fill it I
am good
Oh halfway there god damn it why do I do
this job why do I do this I don't need
to do this it's not like a [ __ ]
internship or anything like that one
what in the world would cause me to do
this I have no idea found you no no I
had it know I'm [ __ ] or nice oh [ __ ]
you know now okay well this is gonna be
fine okay you're gone
perfect Oh
great great of course right and please
let it just be something nearby nope of
course not no I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] of
course I'm [ __ ] there it is god
[ __ ] damn it you make it impossible
you make it [ __ ] impossible [ __ ]
it's the very last one I hit I was on
one of them that was filming god you're
[ __ ] my dick you're [ __ ] my dick
[ __ ] you there's no point in trying to
preempt anything here there's no point
there's exactly zero purpose well I'm
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] if that happens God if
that happens before if that happens when
there's an animatronic in the room
there's nothing I can do there's just
nothing I can do it's death one way or
the other there's just nothing I can do
[Music]
no yep Wow okay yeah see that's that's
fair that's fair yeah that's solely fair
yeah
there's definitely something that I
could have done to avoid that I'm
sitting here waiting for death why okay
well death is gonna come no matter what
I guess yep there it is okay of course
maybe I'm bringing up my console too
much maybe that's like triggering more
stuff because it was it was surprisingly
calm there when I was just sitting and
waiting for death so honestly who knows
it might be a good strategy if I'm like
in the last hour and I just feel like I
need to dive for the finish so what's
the point of these lights you'd think
there would be some greater purpose to
it but I mean why have the lights at all
you know what I mean and there's a
keypad obviously for some kind of a
secret here but I don't know what it is
[Music]
ho-oh
no what the [ __ ] no way not how no way
if that had killed me after the fact I
would have been unbelievably pissed off
and I'm not so let's do this that sack
of [ __ ] was not going to beat me whoa
dude did you know about this there's a
passageway right leading to another
facility right next to this building
that's the choice located at the storage
room maybe there's an unactivated an
ironic there it's worth a try yeah worth
a try I know you're tired oh crap but
think of all what you get if you do this
money recognition you're tired of living
the same boring life every day and
that's why you did this in the first
place
right no no no
Hey
oh well how did lead ecolo do oh okay so
there's gonna be a second update I mean
this is jolly three chapter one okay I'm
a little pissed off at how tough that
last level was but besides all that it
was still a really really good five
nights at Freddy's fan game I can't
fault them for making it challenging
because once I got into it and once I
really understood the strategy it became
a lot easier but it was still very
difficult but that's not a bad thing
because a lot of what five nights at
Freddy's has always been is about a
really difficult task and things just
getting exponentially harder as the time
you go on but this was a really fun one
I am glad that I went through this game
and I'm glad that I I played it to
completion and I'm glad that I was able
to do this for you guys because there
are some games like this out there that
maybe five nights at Freddy's fan games
but there's still really really well
done so I want to see oh yeah hi why is
that flickering that's weird
Maxie George Jolly jolly you don't look
so good I don't like the look at you
Anton okay alright that's okay
metal Freddy hello hi metal Bonnie hello
metal chica and metal foxy chica you
were the biggest [ __ ] alright let's see
this Bargh wait what the wait hang on
speed it up I want to speed it up oh
come on
alright fine roar roar roar yeah yeah
that's a bad one barg
okay Rahr Rahr Rahr Rahr excellent love
it transcripts oh okay well no thanks
BTS Oh coming soon custom night custom
night custom night oh that was oh god oh
oh
ladies night oh boy you know what I'm
okay
I am okay so that was jolly three I'm
not gonna bother with doing the 2020
modes I'm now good at the game and I
probably could with enough perseverance
but I just don't feel like I need to
prove anything at this point so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know he fought down in the comments
below if you want to play this game for
yourself I'll leave a link in the
description and the second chapter this
game should be coming out at some point
the other game that I'm debating playing
is day shift at Freddy's because it just
seems funny and silly and I'm not on
represent sure that I wouldn't enjoy it
very much but I might do that in a
stream setting more than anything else
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always
[Music]